if you go back and look at and we see a
hundred billion galaxies Jordan of those
100 billion galaxies all but 20s show
their light their characteristic
spectrum is shifted to the red some by
tremendous amounts and that implies just
as it would if you were in the city and
you heard all these ambulances and every
single ambulance you heard it as if it
was moving away from you you heard every
siren's whale being redshifted to lower
and lower pitches what would you
conclude you would either conclude
you're at a very special location where
there was just an accident and the
bodies have been cleaned up and taken
away to hospital or that every part of
the city is experiencing all the
ambulance drivers are on strike and
everybody's leaving and so the
interpretation that Edwin hobble and
began to make in 1929 the observation
that every Galaxy exhibits a redshift
that is every Galaxy's moving away from
the Milky Way galaxy The Milky Way
galaxy is no more special or more
important than any other Galaxy
therefore all galaxies to high
approximation are moving away from one
another and that's an astounding
observation a physical fact that we
observe that when extrapolated to the
Future means the universe is going to
become more and more dilute and in the
past it was much more tightly condensed
compressed and presumably began it's
it's in its infancy with what we call
the big bang
[Music]